in must-see TV through the 90s it was an
incredible time where one network one
night for one decade a third of the
country watched NBC they wanted to be a
part of the national conversation or
don't go to work the next day you'd be
left out well the world's change we were
in about a 50 channel universe back then
and we tried to distinguish who we were
today it's a 200 channel universe
television when you want what you want
anywhere everything so do people still
want to be a part of the conversation
you bet but they have twitter they have
blogs they have all kinds of social
networking sites where they can reach
out connect instantly it's never going
to be 75 million people joining together
for that celebration that night it's a
different more competitive world but the
viewer is left with a world of choice
outstanding material on cable television
outstanding material still on network
television and then go to the Internet
Netflix is getting into the game with
original programming more and more
choices for the viewer that's the winner
in this game the more players that want
to create original content and finance
it the more exciting it is in the world
of ideas I play in the world of ideas
after being at a network for 20 years
I'm now in the world of trying to pull
creative people together writers and
producers to create content so it's an
exciting time as far as I'm concerned I
would never bet against Apple um I I've
Apple TV I think that their appetite is
significant and I think they will
continue to play in more and more ways
in how we get information and
entertainment into our homes
and Netflix tremendous service they have
millions and millions of users youtube
well there are moments that you can find
on youtube but there's a big playground
out there and if you can keep your cost
base down and you don't have to live in
that old network model where it's a
million dollars for a 22-minute show
that's a cheap one it's over three
million dollars for an hour it's you
know not unheard of to hit four million
for an hour well there's great content
that can be produced for a lot less than
that it needs to be great the audience
will find great content